تحدث عما تعلمه فريقك عن
هذا المخطط وطول المدة
التي استغرقتها إسرائيل لمراجعة هذه الخطط
ولماذا لم تستمع
إليها، لذا في وقت ما من عام 2022،
تمكنت المخابرات الإسرائيلية من الحصول على
خطة هجوم كاماس التي أطلق عليها كود اسمًا
كان كودن اسمه من قبل
المخابرات الإسرائيلية سور أريحا سور
أريحا وهو يفصل في العديد من التفاصيل الكثيرة
والمختلفة
أه كيف سيتم الهجوم
بالضبط كما حدث بعد أكثر
من عام
من هذا يمكن أن يكون
انتصارا استخباراتيا ل
إسرائيل أم لكن
المحلل الإسرائيلي بعض كبار مسؤولي
المخابرات الإسرائيلية رأوا أن الخطة هي
أكثر مما يسمونها بوصلة لبناء
القوة حيث تريد حماس أن تكون
ولكن ليس ما هو كاماس، لذلك أثناء وجود
هذه الخطة رأوا أن هذا شيء
أن كاماس أبعد ما يكون عن القدرة على
القيام بذلك، ويعتقدون أن حماس
ليس لديها القدرة على القيام بهذه
العملية الضخمة التي نتحدث عنها
وفقًا لتلك الخطة لكسر
السياج بين غزة وإسرائيل في 60
مكانًا مختلفًا اعتقدت إسرائيل أنهم
يستطيعون القيام بها  افعل ذلك ربما في مكانين أم أنه
دعا إلى قصف
الكاميرات وتدميرها على الفور نفس الشيء في وقت
واحد بداية
الهجوم على الكاميرات بالبنادق الآلية
مراكز الاتصالات ثم تصاعد مقر الفرقة مقر فرقة
غزة الموجود في  تم
تكليفها بحماية
الجبهة في شهر يوليو من هذا العام، لذلك
بعد مرور عام على قيام أحد المحللين الذي كان
يراجع
اعتراضات التدريبات العسكرية لحماس
بكتابة رسالة بريد إلكتروني
تبادل بريد إلكتروني مشفر أه
تأتي من 8200 هذا من وكالة الأمن القومي الإسرائيلية أي ما
يعادل  وكالة الأمن القومي الأمريكية
ووصفت ذلك التدريب وقالت إنها
تعتقد أن حماس تعمل على تضييق
الفجوة بين خطة جدار أريحا
وقدراتها الحقيقية وكان هناك
رد من أحد كبار
ضباط المخابرات الأمريكية
قالوا لها إن هذا هو
خطة خيالية لا يمكنهم فعل
ذلك، وبالتالي فإن مأساة
المخابرات الإسرائيلية
للجمهور الإسرائيلي بدلاً من التموضع، لا يعد الأمر
مجرد نقاش استخباراتي، إذا كانت إسرائيل
ستتبنى قوات الدفاع الإسرائيلية هذه
الخطة، فهذا شيء يمكن لكاماس القيام به حتى
دون أي صلة بالنية.
قرار كاماس بتنفيذ هذا هو
الشيء الذي لم يستطع المحلل أن يقوله
أه لم تتراجع عن
الحكمة الإسرائيلية ذلك الوقت يعني
قبل ثلاثة أربعة أشهر أن كاماس لا يريد
الذهاب إلى الكل في واحد لكن إذا إسرائيلي
كانت مؤسسة الدفاع على علم
بأن حماس قادرة على شن مثل هذا
الهجوم
الذي من شأنه أن يضع حجمًا إجماليًا مختلفًا
للقوات على الحدود، وقد
تكون النتيجة مختلفة جدًا، نعم أيضًا وفقًا
لتقاريرك، هذا
المحلل أه هذه المرأة المحللة شاهدت
تمرينًا  أجرت حماس
تجربة تجريبية ورفعت الأعلام الحمراء مرة أخرى
قائلة إن هذا يشبه إلى حد كبير
خطة جدار أريحا التي
ناقشناها من قبل ويبدو أنه قد تم رفضها مرة أخرى،
ليس فقط لأنها
قالت أن هناك بعض المعلومات المثيرة للاهتمام
نفسها  أقتبس من
القرآن
أه الذي يبدأ به أه هذه
الخطة التفصيلية للعمل هذه
الخطة التفصيلية للهجوم تبدأ بدعوى
لهذا هذا شيء عن موسى
لكن الأمر يتعلق أه المفاجأة من خلال
بوابة أعتقد أنها ليست مصادفة
اختارها كاماس  هذا الأمر كان الأشخاص المشاركون في
حكومة كاماس المشاركة في
تلك التدريبات يستخدمون نفس الاقتباس،
نفس الاقتباس أصبح الآن جزءًا من شعار
حماس المستخدم في جميع
بيانات ومقاطع الفيديو الصادرة عن حماس منذ
الهجوم كما تعلمون،
نشرت الحكومة الإسرائيلية على الإنترنت على  X اقتباس الشهر الماضي
يتعارض مع الادعاءات الكاذبة تحت
أي ظرف من الظروف وفي أي وقت تم
تحذير رئيس الوزراء نتنياهو
من نوايا حماس الحربية، واستمروا في
القول بأنه لم يكن هناك أي تحذير في أي وقت من الأوقات
لرئيس الوزراء نتنياهو بشأن
نية حماس لبدء حرب على  على العكس من ذلك، فقد
قدر جميع مسؤولي الدفاع بما في ذلك رؤساء مديرية المخابرات والشينب أن حماس تم
ردعها، هل تعلم ما إذا كان
رئيس الوزراء قد تم إبلاغه بالفعل لأنه
يبدو من تقاريرك أن
هذه
الوثيقة تم نشرها على نطاق واسع في
الدوائر الاستخباراتية والعسكرية  نعم، لذلك لا نعرف ما إذا كان رئيس الوزراء قد
حصل على هذه
الوثيقة التي نعرفها، ونحن نعلم أن هذا يأتي
من تقارير سابقة تفيد بأنه تم
تحذيره مرارًا وتكرارًا
وتكرارًا وبالتفاصيل على الأقل في أربعة
رسائل مختلفة طوال الوقت  أه
العام الماضي الذي أعضاء ما يسمى
أه وجود المقاومة إيران
كاماس يرون الضعف الإسرائيلي
وقد يقررون استغلال ما يعتقدون أنه
فرصة للهجوم نعم
أم هذه الوثيقة أرسلت للكثيرين
وأعتقد أن هذا هو  نقطة جيدة لمزيد من
التقارير حول من رأى نعم ومن
قرر الاستمرار في هذا
المفهوم المزعوم، وهو القدرة على
الاعتقاد بأن حماس تم احتواؤها